personne qui n'aime pas passer par votre
kevin arsenault ne mets jamais de gants
blancs pour dire ce qu'il pense des fois
je suis q lorsque je dis oui mais je
suis une personne qui n'aime pas passé
par quatre chemins des bons journalistes
réputés du parti vert n'entend pas faire
autrement pour sa prochaine mission
il ya un grand risque à prendre en tant
que politicien à s'attaquer à une
compagnie aussi puissante
il veut s'attaquer à la concentration
des médias au nouveau brunswick
en d'autres mots à l'empiré vignes parce
qu'ici 97% des médias anglophones écrits
sont détenus par la famille irving pour
erin starter il s'agit du pire cas de
figure au pays et probablement le pire
en occident une situation préoccupante
parce que les tentacules de ruines ne
s'étendent pas qu'aux médias du papier
toilette eau quincaillerie de la
raffinerie aux stations-service des
chantiers maritimes ou compagnies de
transport de camions ou de train qui
transporte de leurs pommes de terre leur
bois le racing
on estime à plus de 300 le nombre
d'entreprises détenues par la famille
essayait de passer une journée sans
croiser le nom un ring c'est presque
impossible leur entreprise ne sont pas
soumises au même traitement
journalistique que celles qui ne leur
appartiennent pas à titre d'exemple le 9
octobre 2018 une explosion survient à la
raffinerie par bing à saint jean la plus
grande raffinerie au pays
voici la une des journaux en ligne le
lendemain matin miracle à l'action de
grâce dans les journaux nationaux on
pouvait lire explosion à la raffinerie
un vignes des employés sont blessés
quelles conséquences à la suite de cet
incident mais la une du journal local
the miracle à la raffinerie par beaucoup
dont on adore la province
rien de surprenant pour le journaliste
et auteur du livre erwin versus fighting
jacques poitras à un rédacteur
ils ont dit on veut un journal épicé
mais pas trop chaud à une autre aux
acteurs ils ont dit je prends un kaboré
est à moi ils ont je traduis un peu mais
ils ont dit on veut pas que les légendes
journaux brasse la cage simplement pour
brasser la cage diane kevin arseneau on
n'en vient pas il veut briser cette
concentration avec un projet de loi
vieux ça serait de limiter la
possibilité d'une entreprise
d'appartenir plus de 40% des médias donc
lorsqu'il demande qu ici on est une
compagnie bien miley irving au nouveau
brunswick qui ont 97% à peu près des
médiaux écrite anglophone sun le kit la
concentration des médias n'en parlent
depuis belle lurette au nouveau
brunswick et au pays dans les années
soixante dix le comité spécial du sénat
sur les moyens de communication de masse
menée par le sénateur qui dévie conclu
et que c'était une aire désastreuses
pour le journalisme au nouveau brunswick
en 1972 le bureau de la concurrence a
même poursuivi erwin pour monopole des
médias reconnus coupables
les revenus ont fait appel de la
décision et ont gagné en cour suprême du
canada
dix ans plus tard il y a eu la
commission royale d'enquêté sur les
médias menée par le sénateur tom kent
dans ces journalistes du groupe
critiquer ouvertement leur vie ils ne
semblent négliger aucune nouvelle sauf
tout ce qui touche la pollution et leur
entreprise soit environ 85% des
histoires d'intérêt public dans la
province c'est un gros oubli solaire et
le prix médian sino russe les frères vie
n'ont pas manqué de se défendre
nous avons d'excellents bien géré nous
ne sommes pas impliqués dans la prise de
décision posez toutes les questions que
vous voulez et vous aurez la même raison
aujourd'hui on ne sont pas avant ils
sont à nous il conteste le rapport
sénatorial concluait qu'il fallait
défaire les monopoles au pays dont celui
d'hervé tom kent croyait que certaines
des recommandations seraient pas piquer
mais en vain en 2006 le sénat se penche
à nouveau sur cette question oui arrive
aux mêmes conclusions
encore une fois rien n'est fait inquiète
la sociologue irène starter je suis très
inquiète c'est déjà difficile de trouver
de l'information de qualité surtout au
niveau local si ces nouvelles locales
sont couverts par une seule entreprise
tout ce qui touche à ses nombreux
intérêts financiers
on a accès une très mince tranche de
l'information c'est difficile de prendre
des décisions éclairées sur des anges
une assise et pour notre démocratie
ici tout le monde connaît quelqu'un qui
travaille pour l' empire à l'échelle
d'une petite province comme le nouveau
plan grec
ils sont énormes
c'est vraiment l'employeur principal
dans plusieurs communautés incluant
saint jean même le premier ministre
actuel blanc id a été cadre pendant
trente ans chez s'attaquer à ces géants
c'est l'histoire de david contre goliath
kevin arseneau
on est bien conscient juge quand même
très vocal sur la compagnie un ring
nouveau brunswick essayer de trouver un
article qui parle de moi positivement
les journées très difficiles il faut de
la volonté politique et dans une petite
province avec un géant industriel comme
le pire bing on ne mord pas la main qui
nous nourrit